[Música]
[Aplausos]
con cerca de 10 millones de habitantes y
unos 200.000 kilómetros cuadrados
nuestro protagonista de hoy es un país
que últimamente ha destacado sobre todo
por tres cosas primero por ser
considerado Ni más ni menos que como la
última dictadura de Europa segundo por
haber jugado y seguir jugando un papel
clave en la invasión rusa de Ucrania y
tercero exactamente en esta misma línea
por ser el único Aliado europeo que le
queda a la Rusia de Vladimir Putin por
supuesto estamos hablando de la
Bielorrusia de Alexander lukashenko
nunca antes este país había tenido un
protagonismo tan destacado hablamos del
país donde acordaron refugiarse los
wagners tras amotinarse y marchar sobre
Moscú Y por supuesto también Hablamos
del lugar en el que comenzó el día 24 de
febrero de 2022 la propia invasión de
Ucrania no olvidéis que la primera
ofensiva rusa partió de la región
Bielorrusia de Gómez y eso no fue todo
además en para lelo con el avance de las
tropas terrestres la Fuerza Aérea rusa
lanzó docenas de ataques contra
objetivos ucranianos con aviones y
misiles que despegaban y se lanzaban
también desde Bielorrusia
pese a las históricas promesas de
lucashenko de que Ucrania nunca sería
atacada desde su país en los planes
rusos de hacerse con kiev en 72 horas
Bielorrusia jugaba un papel
absolutamente clave aquellos que nos
reprochan no sabían que tenemos la
alianza más cercana con la federación
rusa con ellos estamos construyendo un
estado único poderoso independiente el
estado de la unión hemos estado y
estaremos junto con la Rusia fraterna
nuestra participación en la operación
especial fue decidida por mí hace mucho
tiempo desde entonces Este ha sido con
mucho el país más afectado por las
sanciones internacionales tanto a nivel
económico como político incluso algunas
de las empresas más conocidas del país
han decidido abandonarlo hablamos por
ejemplo de World Gaming la empresa
desarrolladora de juegos tan conocidos
Como este la empresa más grande de
videojuegos de Bielorrusia abandona el
país y Rusia el desarrollo del juego de
guerra World of tanks cierra sus
estudios y traslada la operativa de los
juegos pero sabéis nada de esto es lo
peor lo peor es que transcurrido mucho
tiempo desde que arrancara la guerra
ahora ya no es la soberanía de Ucrania
la que corre peligro sino la de la
propia Bielorrusia Sí sí lo habéis
escuchado bien este país podría llegar a
desaparecer en no mucho tiempo y no
precisamente por ser invadido por
Ucrania o la otan Bielorrusia corre el
riesgo de terminar anexionada por el
gran oso ruso sin ir más lejos el propio
parlamento de Ucrania considera que de
facto Rusia ya lo ha ocupado es
prácticamente la misma posición que
mantiene la oposición bielorrusa en el
exilio y esto ha hecho que en
visualpolitik nos hagamos unas cuantas
preguntas Hasta qué punto corre
Bielorrusia el riesgo de terminar
anexionada por Rusia Qué estaría detrás
de la supuesta intenciones de Moscú
porque lucashenko parece no hacer nada
al respecto Pues bien en este vídeo
responderemos a estas y otras preguntas
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas Bielorrusia tiene
básicamente un gran problema bajo la
perspectiva de Moscú Este no es
realmente un país extranjero o uno del
todo independiente más bien lo ven como
una especie de territorio autónomo que
de alguna forma pertenece realmente a la
propia madre Rusia y claro como os
podéis suponer conociendo todos los
antecedentes esto es sumamente
inquietante pero lo peor es que no se
trata de una perspectiva exclusivamente
rusa
cuando lucasenko llegó al poder en 1994
lo hizo ganando unas elecciones en las
que su campaña se basó sobre todo en la
integración con Rusia particularmente en
el ámbito económico pero no
exclusivamente digamos que en su día
lucashenko recibió el apoyo político y
económico de Moscú a cambio de reforzar
la cosmovisión rusa
de hecho la identidad bielorrusa que
durante años ha promovido y sigue
promoviendo el propio régimen se basa
sobre todo en el culto al pasado en la
gran guerra patriótica la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y la hermandad con la propia
Rusia del resto del pasado de
Bielorrusia ni papa Incluso el propio
lucashenko ha llegado a decir en la
televisión Estatal que los bielorrusos
en esencia son rusos con sello de
calidad Sí sí así tal cual de hecho fue
en gran medida esta posición lo que
explica que en 1999
Moscú y Minsk firmaran un tratado
bilateral para constituir
progresivamente el llamado estado de la
unión En otras palabras que los dos
países decidieron fusionarse Bueno
fusionarse fusionarse no pero sí
reforzar hasta el extremo su integración
social política y económica con
instituciones conjuntas hablamos por
ejemplo de una moneda común o un código
tributario unificado
por ahora nos ha llegado a tanto pero
desde el primer momento sí que se
estableció la libertad de movimiento
entre ambos países y la unificación de
ambos mercados laborales de esta forma
rusos y los bielorrusos no necesitan ni
permisos en ningún otro documento
particular para trabajar en cualquiera
de los dos países pero con todo la
pregunta que tenemos que hacernos es por
qué Bielorrusia decidió dar este
importante paso a ver Aparentemente
tenía todas las de perder no os parece
un país pequeño asociándose con uno
muchísimo más grande está claro que
Moscú terminaría tomando todas las
decisiones no es así pues no lo cierto
Es que no O al menos eso no fue lo que
pensó lucashenko fijaos
los años 90 fueron muy duros para Rusia
el país vivía sumergido en una constante
crisis y eso despertó la ambición del
líder bielorruso ya os lo hemos contado
en alguna que otra ocasión lucasenko
llegó a pensar que muchos órganos
conjuntos el peso de poder de Rusia y
Bielorrusia sería exactamente el mismo
incluso llegó a pensar que él mismo
podría dirigir esa especie de
supraestado por supuesto El paso del
tiempo hizo que las cosas empezaran a
verse de forma totalmente diferente
hasta el punto de que Bielorrusia no
hablamos de una asociación sino del
riesgo real de anexión a Rusia
y la pregunta es pero es que acaso
lucashenko fue tan ingenuo cómo puede
ser que el último dictador de Europa o
sea un tipo al que se la juegan tan
fácilmente pues lo cierto Es que esto no
es del todo así El dictador bielorruso
siempre tuvo un ojo Mirando a Rusia y
otro Mirando a occidente hasta que un
buen día todo eso cambió qué fue lo que
ocurrió Qué pasó para que minnes
prácticamente se rindiera a Moscú Pues
bien veámoslo
Haz calculada
Poco después de firmarse el tratado del
estado de la unión comenzó el superciclo
de las materias primas y el petróleo que
consolidó la primera etapa de Putin al
frente de Rusia durante esos años los
dólares empezaron a fluir hacia Rusia
como si no hubiera mañana y por supuesto
Bielorrusia se benefició de toda esa
repentina ola de prosperidad sus
exportaciones al gigante ruso se
dispararon muchos jóvenes se trasladaron
al país vecino a trabajar y por supuesto
la inversión directa de compañías rusas
en el país se multiplicó fueron los años
dorados de la Bielorrusia de lucashenko
pero amigos no era oro todo lo que
relucía había un problema un gran
problema que no dejaba dormir al
dictador bielorruso Y es que al poco
tiempo de llegar Putin al poder
lucasenko entendió perfectamente que el
nuevo mandamás ruso no era como yelsin y
que por tanto sus planes de pilotar el
estado conjunto que habían acordado
crear estaban condenados al más absoluto
de los fracasos
entonces en Miss que empezaron a dar
largas sobre el proyecto y no solo eso
cuando los precios del petróleo se
desinflaron el gobierno Bielorrusia
aprovechó la ocasión para dejar de mirar
directamente a Moscú y empezar a prestar
más atención a occidente en la Diana
estaba el gigantesco mercado de la Unión
Europea
[Música]
Y eso ni siquiera es todo también
comenzó a cultivar una identidad
nacional propia una que fuera más allá
de Rusia en 2014 por ejemplo varios
medios de comunicación rusos empezaron a
culpar al líder bielorruso de coquetear
con el nacionalismo Y tratar de
suplantar la cultura rusa hay una
campaña rusofobica no declarada
Bielorrusia y se está complaciendo
abiertamente a las fuerzas nacionalistas
el gobierno tomó sibilinamente todo tipo
de medidas algunas tan simbólicas como
sustituir en las celebraciones las
cintas de San Jorge que se utilizan
mucho en Rusia por cintas verde y rojas
que imitan los colores de la bandera
oficial también en 2018 el régimen llegó
a permitir que quien dice que hasta
alentar las celebraciones públicas por
el centenario de la república bielorrusa
que se declaró en 1918 tras separarse
temporalmente de Rusia el primer intento
de Independencia Nacional de su historia
moderna como os podéis imaginar todo un
símbolo para los movimientos
nacionalistas Pero estos son solo dos
ejemplos de un movimiento que buscaba
claramente y por primera vez reforzar
una verdadera identidad nacional
Claro en esa época el régimen bielorruso
ya se había vuelto mucho más precavido
respecto a la nueva Rusia de Putin no se
fiaban de ellas sabían que de no
consolidar una Clara identidad nacional
y empezar a buscar alternativas
comerciales y económicas el país tarde o
temprano sería engullido por Rusia
incluso estuvieron dispuestos a
renunciar a ciertas subvenciones a
cambio de más Independencia económica y
política en ese momento más allá de las
apariencias Lo cierto es que las
relaciones entre mins y Moscú no eran
precisamente las mejores de hecho a
comienzos del 2020 Rusia le llegó a
cortar a este país el suministro de
petróleo y restableció los controles
fronterizos al movimiento de personas
para que os hagáis una idea de cómo
estaban las cosas lucashenko se negó en
todo momento a reconocer la anexión rusa
de crimea para él crimea seguía siendo
Ucrania y también decía cosas como estas
y en los Rusia nunca permitiría que
otros países usen nuestro territorio
para una intervención militar en Ucrania
El problema es que lo de mirar occidente
a veces resulta más fácil de decir que
de hacer especialmente si eres una
dictadura con puño de hierro y tienes
una economía terriblemente obsoleta en
el caso de Bielorrusia básicamente lo
que podía exportar a la Unión Europea
eran commodities y productos de bajo
valor añadido madera metal patatas y
sobre todo productos petroquímicos
Y es que veréis Bielorrusia tiene una
enorme capacidad instalada para producir
combustibles y derivados del petróleo el
problema que toda esa industria la mayor
del país depende básicamente del
suministro ruso de petróleo barato con
lo que al tiempo que incrementaba sus
exportaciones al oeste aumentaba su
dependencia de Rusia no era una
situación fácil pero en cualquier caso
Lo cierto es que cada vez había más
distancia entre Moscú y Minsk digamos
que fue la gran oportunidad de sacarte
una vez por todas a Bielorrusia de la
Esfera de control del kremlin sin
embargo amigos de repente en 2020 todo
este proceso se vino abajo y no no fue
por lo que estáis pensando en toda esta
historia el responsable no fue la Kobe
19 sino las elecciones presidenciales
fijaos
el día 9 de agosto de 2020 se celebraron
elecciones presidenciales la candidatura
de lucasenco se hizo oficialmente con
algo más del 80% de los votos por
supuesto estas elecciones estuvieron
casi tan amañadas como una carrera de
atletismo en Corea del Norte en la que
participará el mismísimo quiñón Y eso
hizo estallar enormes protestas
pacíficas exigiendo un cambio de juego
en el país las protestas fueron tan
grandes y contaron además con tanto
apoyo internacional que por primera vez
el régimen bielorruso estuvo contra las
cuerdas Y eso ni siquiera es todo para
colmo los bielorrusos comenzaron a
retirar masivamente dinero de los bancos
intentaron por todas las vías convertir
su rubro locales a monedas más fuertes
como el dólar o el euro por lo que
pudiera pasar en un mes los bielorrusos
prácticamente agotaron las reservas del
Banco Central e instituciones como el
fmi se negaron a acudir en su auxilio el
país estaba al borde del colapso y la
dictadura de lucasenco parecía aprender
de un hilo solo quedaba una salida
echarse en brazos de Rusia
y sabéis que dicho y hecho eso fue
exactamente lo que hizo
el régimen bielorruso pidió auxilio a
Vladimir Putin y en apenas unos días
Rusia aprobó un primer rescate de 1500
millones de dólares luego junto a ese
rescate financiero Rusia también
prometió asistencia militar Vladimir
Putin ha ofrecido enviar asistencia
militar Para apoyar al presidente de
Bielorrusia Alexander lucasenco mientras
200.000 manifestantes se reúnen para
pedir su dimisión Y luego el kremlin
también envió a todo tipo de
profesionales de la propaganda y la
represión sin ir más lejos los canales
de televisión fueron prácticamente
tomados por propagandistas rusos
propagandistas que por supuesto estaban
a las órdenes de Moscú y no de vins
amigos amigas sea como sea la cuestión
es que con toda esta ayuda y con la
garantía de que el ejército ruso
impediría cualquier tipo de sublevación
contra el gobierno bielorruso lucasenco
pudo aumentar la represión y la
persecución a toda la oposición política
sin temer las consecuencias en 2021
incluso pasó esto os acordáis Ryan
afirma que Bielorrusia ha obligado a
aterrizar a uno de sus aviones tal cual
la fuerza aérea bielorrusa forzó el
aterrizaje mint de un avión de ryanair
que volaba entre Atenas y billiums para
detener a Roman protasevich y a su
pareja Sofía sapega protasevich es un
periodista crítico y activista de la
oposición con asilo en la Unión Europea
un momento a ver obligará a aterrizar a
un avión comercial europeo volando entre
dos ciudades europeas enviando para ello
Incluso un caza y todo para detener a
una persona con asilo político en Europa
por supuesto eso suponía cruzar todas
las líneas rojas pero en ese momento en
mins Gracias al apoyo de Moscú se lo
podían permitir solo había un problema
los regalos casi nunca son gratis y
desde luego en este caso no lo fueron
a cambio de toda esta ayuda el dictador
bielorruso tuvo que reconocerle al
kremlin mucha más influencia que nunca
incluso tuvo que comprometerse a sacar
adelante una reforma constitucional que
por ejemplo permiti el despliegue
permanente de tropas rusas en el país de
locos por supuesto como os podéis
imaginar todo este proceso vino
acompañado por un montón de nuevas
sanciones por parte de la comunidad
internacional lo que evidentemente
profundizó aún más la dependencia de
Rusia digamos que la era de mirar
accidente había llegado a su fin para
siempre y ahí queridos amigos ahí Todo
cambió durante años Bielorrusia se había
opuesto frontalmente a la apertura en el
país de bases militares rusas entendían
lógicamente que eso suponía una amenaza
intolerable sin embargo tras el rescate
del 2020 ya no quedó más remedio que
aceptar las exigencias rusas
Pero eso no fue todo a partir del 2020
también se puso en marcha por parte del
gobierno bielorruso una fuerte retórica
antioccidental el estado de la unión
volvió a Primera Plana se utilizó a
decenas de miles de inmigrantes de
oriente medio y África para causar en
2021 una crisis política y humanitaria
en la frontera con Polonia lituania y en
noviembre de ese mismo año Miss
reconoció por primera vez a crimea como
parte de Rusia y aún más también se puso
en marcha una intensaficación en todo el
país hasta se retiraron del Museo
Nacional esculturas de los gobernantes
del Gran ducado de lituania a partir de
ahora el pasado de Bielorrusia solo
puede pasar al menos oficialmente por
Rusia
[Música]
ahora bien no son únicamente las razones
políticas Los lazos con el resto del
mundo o las cuestiones culturales
identitarias lo que hacen peligrar la
independencia de Bielorrusia Lo cierto
es que este país está cada vez más y más
sumergido en Rusia de hecho resulta
difícil muy difícil decir que todavía
estamos ante un país independiente pero
queréis saber exactamente de qué estamos
hablando pues atentos
una Opa hostil
queridos amigos la invasión rusa de
Ucrania hizo de Bielorrusia un estado
paria y lo marginó por completo en los
mercados internacionales la comunidad
internacional le aplicó prácticamente
las mismas sanciones que Rusia con una
gran diferencia este país no tiene
petróleo gas ni tecnología nuclear con
la que jugar en el tablero geopolítico
mundial de hecho Bielorrusia no tiene
nada con lo que jugar y eso explica
Porque aquí las sanciones han sido mucho
más demoledoras que en la propia Rusia
por ejemplo tan solo en los primeros
meses de la guerra las exportaciones de
Bielorrusia a la Unión Europea se
desplomaron casi un 60%. algunas de las
empresas más pujantes abandonaron el
país la industria tuvo que despedir a
más del 15% de sus trabajadores los
salarios en los sectores sancionados se
desplomaron y en su conjunto la economía
cayó en 2022 casi un 5% siendo
optimistas y claro como ya os hemos
contado todo esto ha hecho que hoy
Bielorrusia sea mucho más dependiente de
la madre patria Rusia que nunca antes
pero ahora bien la pregunta que tenemos
que hacernos es hasta dónde llega
realmente toda esta dependencia
pues lo cierto es que es casi total es
tan grande que una de las grandes vías
de ingresos públicos del país consiste
en revender en el mercado internacional
una parte del petróleo que recibe a
precios subvencionados de Rusia hablamos
según los cálculos de un beneficio en
2022 de 1700 millones de dólares solo
con esta operativa en 2023 se espera que
sean casi 3.000 millones por supuesto en
Rusia conocen esta operativa Y sabéis
qué en última instancia no les importa
son ellos quienes tienen el control del
Grifo del crudo de hecho una de las
principales exportaciones del país son
los combustibles producidos a partir del
petróleo ruso algo que durante años fue
alentado por Moscú que mejor forma de
controlar un país si su principal
industria depende exclusivamente de ti y
ni siquiera se trata solo del petróleo
que revende o El combustible que exporta
en total más de dos tercios de la
energía que el país consume bien procede
Rusia o bien está controlada por
empresas rusas En otras palabras que en
el contexto actual si Moscú cortan al
Grifo Bielorrusia prácticamente podría
quedarse a oscuras pero si os parece
vayamos Más allá de la energía cerca de
la mitad de toda la deuda pública del
país está en manos de Rusia luego con la
inversión extranjera directa pasa tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo y para colmo
muchas empresas públicas rusas controlan
activos clave en Bielorrusia hablamos de
bancos empresas de telecomunicaciones o
refinerías y lo que es aún peor se
estima que hoy por hoy entre el 60 y el
70% de todas las exportaciones
bielorrusias van a parar a la tierra de
Vladimir Putin es decir que desde un
punto de vista económico ya no podemos
hablar de un país completamente
independiente
todo esto explica Por qué cuando Rusia
quiso invadir Ucrania y tomar Give en
tres días utilizará precisamente este
país lucasenko no podía oponerse de
hecho desde que dio comienzo la invasión
de Ucrania este país ha sido una de las
principales bases de lanzamiento de
misiles le han entregado al ejército
ruso parte sustancial de sus arsenales
militares les ha permitido el uso
intensivo de sus ferrocarriles y
carreteras Incluso se ha convertido en
un centro médico clave para los soldados
caídos o heridos en el frente
[Música]
pero un momento Esto no es nada nuevo
porque decimos que ahora existe un
riesgo real de anexión por parte de
Rusia pues amigos porque Bielorrusia
puede terminar convirtiéndose en una
especie de trofeo de consolación
pensando bien termine como termine la
Guerra de Ucrania está claro que esta
campaña ha sido y será un rotundo
fracaso Y claro a ningún tirano le gusta
presentarse como alguien Derrotado Putin
prometió proteger y hacer más grande a
Rusia pero eso ya no pasa por Ucrania
durante años Bielorrusia intentó hacer
malabarismos sacar provecho de los o
ruso sin caer del todo en sus garras
ahora eso ya no parece posible Putin lo
sabe Y parece más que dispuesto a sacar
tajada de esta situación una forma sería
forzando la anexión a Rusia bajo el
marco del estado de la Unión o cualquier
otro invento político como la recreación
de los estados satélites de la antigua
Unión soviética de esta forma podría
vender una Rusia más grande y fuerte un
éxito en el marco de una tremenda
derrota política económica y militar
desde el punto de vista del kremlin no
es una mala jugada no os parece
amigos amigas todo apunta A qué
Bielorrusia de una forma u otra puede
estar a punto de perder su soberanía si
es que no la ha perdido ya el intento de
dar refugio A los Wagner fue Quizás El
último intento de lucasenco de
asegurarse un mayor margen de maniobra
pero con la caída de pregotzin eso ya es
historia hoy por hoy Bielorrusia tiene
muchas papeletas desaparecer del mapa
sea como sea y dado que no tenemos una
bola de cristal si os parece lo mejor
que podemos hacer es abrir el debate
pensáis que Rusia se anexionará
definitivamente Bielorrusia lo
convertirá en un estado completamente
subordinado o por contra lucashenko y el
resto de gerifaltes de mins podrán
mantener el tipo qué debería hacer
occidente ante toda esta historia
déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y por supuesto si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle al botón de like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo has
hecho muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]